in the opening scene we see a garbage
truck driving through the streets of a
Suburban neighborhood with two workers
hanging on its sides a former soldier
named Lawson who in proper 80s fashion
wakes up next to a woman nine times as
attractive as him wakes up and is
surprised by the early morning arrival
of the garbage truck thinking that the
schedule has been changed he hurriedly
gets up and rushes outside with his
trash as he approaches the garbage truck
the two men reveal themselves as
assassins who then pull out the mini ues
and gun lwen down to death later on one
of the Assassins cook is seen in a car
dealership the owner who is also an army
veteran is briefing him about the
vehicles not long after Cook gets inside
a vehicle says the best thing about it
is the price and then drives away in it
after running over the owner he then
proceeds to a harbor where he keeps a
close eye on a sailor named Bennett who
is another former Army member as soon as
Bennett departs in the tugboat cook
activates a Remote device causing the
entire boat to detonate the scene then
cuts to a former United States Army
Special Forces member named Colonel John
Matrix that's you're godamn right John
Matrix who lives in the mountains of
Upstate California with his young
daughter Jenny after going through the
daily chores the father and daughter are
having their breakfast when they see an
army helicopter approaching as the
helicopter lands Major General Franklin
Kirby steps out and orders his Two
Soldiers to secure the area Franklin
then meets Jon who sneaks up on him
which is ridiculous cuz he's the size of
a whale and informs him that there is a
problem all the other members of his
former unit have been killed by unknown
mercenaries and Jon's life is also in
danger in order to ensure he and his
daughter's safety Franklin leaves his
soldiers behind moments after the major
general departs a group of gunmen
launches an attack on the secluded home
resulting in the deaths of the two
soldiers who fr Franklin Kirby literally
just said were his best guys Jon somehow
manages to grab his daughter and takes
cover within the house he instructs his
little girl to hide in her bedroom while
he rushes to the shed to retrieve his
rifle armed and ready Jon returns to
Jenny's room only to be confronted by
another assassin named Diaz Diaz informs
him that his people have taken Jenny
away and that Jon must cooperate with
him if he wishes to see her alive right
he says wrong says Jon and shoots Diaz
in in the face before pursuing the other
asants he rushes outside only to
discover that his Jeep has been disabled
despite this setback he pushes the
vehicle down a hill and uses its
momentum to chase after the attackers he
manages to intercept one of their
vehicles but a group of armed men
overpower him you know it's going to be
a good movie when the bad guy is wearing
a hammock they then tranquilize Jon a
while later Jon regains his
Consciousness and finds himself in a
room chained to a table much to his
shock he is greeted by Bennett who had
been thought to have been killed in the
tugboat explosion it turns out that
Bennett is the one behind all those
killings and had faked his own death to
smoke out Franklin and Jon Bennett
claims that he's doing this for Revenge
because Jon discharged him from the Army
for killing civilians soon after they
are approached by a former South
American dictator Arius who was
overthrown from Power by Jon's team arus
blackmails Jon into assassinating the
new president in his home country of
valde so that he can rise to power once
again with his daughter's life on the
line Jon seemingly agrees to fulfill the
demand afterwards Jon is escorted to the
airport where he meets Henrik this
mercenary will be accompanying him
throughout his mission upon boarding the
plane Jon requests a flight attendant
get him a pillow and a blanket seizing
the right opportunity he swiftly kills
henrik's with a single elbow careful
they pointy he swiftly kills Henrik and
positions his body in such a way that it
appears as if he is asleep John then
proceeds to the plane's cargo hold and
jumps from the plane just as it's taking
off I'm sorry but that you see that that
was some it's an 11-hour flight
which means that Jon has 11 hours to
find arus and free his daughter his
first lead brings him to Sully one of
aras's men who had come to drop him off
at the airport earlier Sully is
currently seen talking to Aras on the
phone informing him of the flight's
departure after the call he heads to his
vehicle unaware that Jon is is tailing
him in the parking lot Jon forces the
assistance of an off-duty flight
attendant named Cindy he rips the seat
out of her car so that he can sit more
comfortably and instructs her to follow
Sully's car drive tiny woman shortly
after they arrive at a shopping mall
where Jon confides in Cindy about his
situation and requests her help he urges
her to approach Sul and seduce him so
that he can extract information about
aras's whereabouts although Cindy
initially pretends to be cooperative she
she ultimately reports Jon to a mall
security guard addressing him as a
kidnapper which you know he is the guard
then calls for backup and a group of
guards confront him as a result a
physical altercation ensues between them
in the midst of the chaos Sully notices
Jon and rushes to a pay phone to inform
his boss but before he can make the call
Jon rips off the wires and destroys the
entire Booth he just shakes it until all
the glass falls out and su's too scared
to shoot his gun at him and he just
lifts it over his head and
then the security guards surround Jon
earning suly enough time to run away but
despite this he fights them off throws
them all away like he's the Hulk and
then he runs after Sully one of the
guards tries to shoot him but Cindy who
has realized her mistake I guess after
she's seen him beat a ton of cops up
pushes him down the stairs before
fleeing in the next scene Jon pursues
Sully to the parking lot where Cindy
also joins him then a lengthy car chase
ensues during this Cindy who is
completely frazzled by what's happening
fires off a barrage of questions but Jon
remains solely focused on driving she
says aren't you going to explain this to
me and Jon says no the chase eventually
ends when Sully's car flips over while
the other two crash into a pole John
then walks over to Sully and retrieves a
motel room key from his pocket he holds
him over a steep Cliff demanding
information on Jenny's whereabouts Sully
tries to negotiate offering to take him
to cook who knows everything however
John is is already aware of Sully's
planned meeting with cook at the motel
so he drops him off the cliff to his
death have a nice fall following this
John and Cindy make their way to the
designated Motel on the other hand arus
and Bennett Drive Jenny to a villa
located on a private island they lock
the little girl in a room before walking
away later on arus inquires about the
remaining time until Jon's plane lands
and whether they should anticipate any
trouble in response Bennett reassures
him stating that there are still over 2
hours left and that Jon will not take
any such step that will risk his
daughter's life on the way to the motel
Jon finally reveals the entire ordeal to
Cindy also showing her Jenny's picture
he tells her that he must find his
daughter before arus and Bennett find
out that he did not carry out their job
after driving for a while the duo arrive
at the motel they use the key and enter
the designated room they then starts
searching around hoping to find any
clues a short while later cook arrives
at the motel and knocks on on their door
in a quick action Jon turns on the
shower and instructs Cindy to pretend as
if she was having a good time with Sully
she then takes off her blazer and
answers the door introducing herself as
Sully's dat as soon as cook steps inside
the room Jon attacks him from behind a
fierce brawl ensues between the two
strong guys although the entire time it
just kind of feels like a joke that this
dude could get a single hid in on
schwarzy in the midst of this cook
reveals that he's a former Green Beret
and threatens to kill him but Jon
appears to be uneffective Ed by this
Revelation as they fight he pushes cook
through the wall and they end up in the
adjacent room startling a woman who is
pegging her boyfriend the fight
eventually comes to an end when Jon
impales him on a table leg as a result
of this cook dies before he can reveal
Jenny's location John and Cindy then
head outside to investigate Cook's
vehicle they soon come across a fuel
receipt with an address for a private
plane hanger without any delay they take
Cook's car and drive towards the hanger
upon their arrival Jon realizes that it
is the same place where he woke after
getting tranquilized he infiltrates the
facility through the roof and discovers
an entire operation of aras's Rebel
soldiers engaged in weapon smuggling he
hides himself from the workers and
manages to sneak into the control room
after incapacitating one of the workers
there he opens the window allowing Cindy
to enter through it upon looking around
they find a map and figure out an island
on the coastal region where Jenny is
being held it's pure video game logic
and it's SL CS before heading to the
island John firstly stops by a surplus
store breaks into it and equips himself
with military weaponry including
Firearms explosives and a freaking
rocket launcher Cindy takes all those
weapons to the car but Jon is arrested
by the police before he can join her
seeing this Cindy follows the police van
and uses the rocket launcher to whoops
fire fire backwards but then again to
free him from police captivity after
this the two drive towards the nearby
Marina where they B a sea plane and set
off for the island meanwhile at the
island Villa Jenny cleverly makes an
attempt to escape from the room JN and
Cindy land just off the coast of the
island the following morning at the same
time the airplane lands in valde and
henrique's Dead face is revealed Jon
instructs Cindy to keep trying to
contact the major general while he
boards a dinghy before sailing towards
the shore she sees him without his shirt
on and gives him one of those looks like
she doesn't even know how that makes her
feel he then then Dawns up his battle
suit equips himself with all the weapons
and makes his way to the Villa he sets
up a number of time bombs throughout the
island base before moving further amidst
this he also kills some of aras's
soldiers on his way at the valde airport
aras's henchmen wait for the arrival of
JN and Henrik before long they can see a
dead body being carried out on a
stretcher the men check the dead body's
face and learn that it is Enrique I
think I finally just got his name right
this prompts the men to call arus and
inform him about the same after hearing
this news the power hungry dictator
orders Bennett to kill the little girl
but as Bennett advances towards Jenny's
room Jon triggers the bombs exploding
the tents and little Huts surrounding
the Villa after a while Bennett somehow
enters Jenny's room only to notice that
the little girl has just escaped
prompting him to chase her in the
meantime Jon continues to kill the
hordes of aras's troops using the rocket
launcher the rifles and the explosives
as well as Buzz Saws and while
making his way to the Villa at one point
he grabs a machine gun and takes down a
number of the enemies they're all aiming
straight at him but they can't hit him
and he's aiming at nothing and killing
everyone eventually Jon enters the Villa
where he is confronted by an armed arus
after a bit of a gunfight Jon ultimately
manages to kill him with a shotty on the
other hand Bennett follows the young
girl to the basement and captures her at
the same time Jon hears his daughter's
scream and rushes to her Aid he
eventually tracks them down but Bennett
suddenly opens fire and a bullet
penetrates his right shoulder despite
the injury John taunts Bennett to a
knife duel a challenge that the ladder
accepts why the hell would anyone
challenge Arnold Schwarzenegger to a
knife duel and after a lengthy and
intense fight between the two former
comrades Jon ultimately kills Bennett by
hurling a steam pipe into his chest
finally ending the battle okay Bennett
why don't you let off some steam in the
aftermath Major General Franklin arrives
at the scene and notices Jon walking out
with his daughter looking like the
biggest movie star in the world he then
extends an offer for Jon to rejoin his
Commando unit however our hero declines
the offer stating no chance the movie
ends as Jon departs the island aboard
the sea plane with Jenny and Cindy
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching